hey guys we're midway through the 2012  season and there's a ton of new anime  for you to check out and definitely one  of our favorites around here is kokoro  connect if you've never heard of seen it  before it starts off with five members  of schools culture club whose lives are  inextricably changed as their  personalities switched without any  warning at first the five students find  this entertaining but as the personality  switching gets a little out of hand so  do their relationships with one another  um it's not a new subject by any stretch  of the imagination to tackle but it  approaches the idea elegantly subtly and  will surprise you without any morning  this is really the only thing we can say  without you know brewing it twists and  turns of this anime so there's gonna be  a series that you check out this season  let it be kokoro connect connect we're  connected get it